elements of the 25th Infantry Division
prepare to launch Operation Longfellow
on the 17th of April
from this jumping-off point at docto in
calm tomb province 480 kilometers north
northeast of Saigon the troops head for
LG Ohio 32 kilometers to the north one
of the primary missions of this
operation is to relocate modern yard
tribesmen from this area to the
resettlement camp at duck toe the men
move up through some of the most rugged
country of the central highlands a short
way from the LZ a CP is established as
some of the traffic lightening troops
secure the area this wilderness area has
never before been penetrated by American
troops and reports indicate the Vietcong
are literally holding the mountain yard
villagers in bondage seizing their
livestock and crops more than 1,500
mutton yards will be rescued from the
enemy before operation long follow is
concluded two days after the start of
Operation Longfellow medevac choppers
bring the wounded to the field hospital
at docto emergency treatment has given
the patients here only minutes after a
wound is received in battle the medical
team at this forward Area facility
quickly completes its job and the
patient is then carried back to the
waiting helicopter to be airlifted to
the base hospital this Swift efficient
method of moving the wounded from
battlefield to hospital has resulted in
the saving of many thousands of lives
since the beginning of American
participation in the fighting in Vietnam
these troopers of the 1st Infantry
Division are commencing phase one of
tactical exercise Lexington the
operation is taking place in the
long-term area some 64 kilometers east
of Saigon it will continue from 17 to 28
April this phase of the operation is a
hunt and kill mission to dislodge any
Vietcong entrenched in the area for one
week the camera recorded the activities
of a rifle platoon engaged in operations
against the Vietnamese communist forces
most of the first day was spent in a
route march which would carry the men
deep into Viet Cong dominated territory
to reach a remote village the men spend
hours moving through jungles until
finally the platoon leader orders a
bivouac area set up for the night while
some of the men start digging in others
are sent out on security patrols to make
sure the area is safe for overnight and
testaments trip flares will be set up
around the camp perimeter as an added
precaution against any surprise attack
during the night anyone stumbling over
these wires in the darkness will set off
the armed flares lighting the night
but the precaution proved unnecessary
the players were never fired and the
night passed without incident the
following morning the 18th of April the
rifleman moved out sentry dog and all
through the heavy underbrush once again
they were headed for the nameless
collection of patched huts in the forest
ahead sometime around midday they
reached the edge of a large cocoa palm
grove on the perimeter of the objective
village quietly taking up positions in
the surrounding cover the men observed
the village for a long time
failing to spot any armed enemy the foot
soldiers entered the hamlet and
interpreters questioned the residents
and examined their papers following a
house-to-house search the troopers
settled back for a badly needed rest
during the course of the morning they
had covered more than 6000 metres most
of it was dense undergrowth finally
satisfied that no Vietcong were to be
found here the platoon began moving back
toward the LZ the day-long march on
April 19 culminates with all members of
the platoon reaching the appointed
landing zone without mishap at the end
of three days there has been no contact
with the enemy the choppers come in for
the pickup and the perspiring troopers
are mighty glad to get aboard soldiering
in the humid jungles of Vietnam is
physically demanding even for our well
conditioned infantrymen at home base the
men hastened for their 10:00
the next day the platoon is ordered into
the wrong shop area along the Saigon
River it is called the mangrove swamp
phase two of Lexington gets underway as
the same weapons platoon boards lcvps
less than 72 kilometers from Saigon
mission in this phase is to probe the
swamps for any Vietcong infiltrators or
smugglers and the landing point is
reached the mud here creates a suction
that threatens to remove a man's boot
coffee-colored streams are crossed with
the aid of a stout rope and in the
interior are snake infested thickets and
quicksand bogs one man is felled by the
hundred degree heat
after four hours of hunting the enemy
the platoon discovers a trail on high
ground and it is decided to set up an
ambush
the infantryman in Vietnam spends most
of his time searching for the VC a radio
check is made with other First Division
units once the trap has been set then
the watching and waiting begins the
hours are filled with insects and heats
and swamp noises but there are no
Vietcong the troops start back for the
boats and again have to forward rain
swollen creeks with the deep holes
encountered in crossing the rope is
absolutely necessary reaching their
forward camp the men are thirsty and
exhausted their water supply had been
depleted during the long trip back and
they settle down for the night with the
coming of daylight the platoon moves out
and by mid-morning
they are aboard the waiting boats and
sailing up the placid waters of the song
Saigon the men begin two days of rest
most of the first day is spent sleeping
and airing their clothes their weapons
are meticulously clean in a moment of
complete relaxation the members of the
platoon have a cookout as one of the
sergeants turns out charcoal hamburgers
the day is made complete as the mail
arrives and the men munch while getting
the word from home all part of the life
of a foot soldier in Vietnam
at BOM brieng near the end of March for
Viet Cong are taken prisoner by a recon
platoon of the u.s. 25th Infantry
Division they are turned over to a
brigade military intelligence team who
will put them through an intensive
interrogation
also at bomb brieng an attempt is made
to recover a crashed aircraft this down
the sky rater is to be picked up by a
flying crane preparations by the crew
for the aerial pickup are underway the
flying crane standby for the signal to
begin straps are placed at carrying
points on the plane to form the harness
for the lift in a cloud of dust the CH
54 flying crane struggles with its load
but the sky rater proves to be
unmanageable and crashes back to earth
junction of the song Bay and song
Donghai rivers stands the chi-chi
Special Forces camp
although fully operational it is being
strengthened in depth by Vietnamese
civilian workers some of whom are shown
here making bricks for fortifications
located 45 kilometers northeast of
Benoit Chi Chi is the early-warning
outpost of a larger US Special Forces
camp some cut this plaque is being
erected in honor of zom cops former
commanders in memory of captain Leo
Michael donker killed in action 3 April
1966 Chi Chi established in February in
a Viet Cong controlled area is manned by
Vietnamese personnel called strikers
they are shown here lined up for revelry
as their company commander selects they
patrol this observation tower symbolizes
Chi Chi as defenses living quarters are
join the defense bunkers another
observation tower atop a concrete
emplacement is manned by a striker who
keeps a watchful eye beyond the
perimeter and placed mortars are ready
for the VC barbed wire lines a ditch in
which claymore mines are laid concertina
wire adds to the perimeter defense drums
of gasoline connected to explosive
charges are designed to create a wall of
fire around the camp Chi Kai's defenses
are strong and getting stronger with VC
reported in the area US Special Forces
fire a 75 millimeter recoilless rifle at
an enemy concentration and are supported
by an airstrike
US and Vietnamese cap personnel watch
the strike a Vietnamese Sam fan paddled
by in the foreground
while Skyraiders continued the air
attack as the air strike lifts a US
Special Forces advisor joins a Stryker
Patrol which will proceed down river by
boat to determine the effectiveness of
the attack
on the banks of the Songhua River just
outside the town of unque is located the
only pure water point serving the first
Air Cavalry Division and it's supporting
units van mounted water purification
systems are operated by the Army
engineers troops are supplied from
gravity-feed storage tanks after river
water has been processed and pumped into
the tanks up to 6,000 gallons of water
per minute can be supplied the wash
point a short distance below the water
supply point on the river is constantly
busy the division vehicles and a host of
other items like these cots are scrubbed
down here everything from 5 ton trucks
to jeeps and trailers gets washed in the
waters of the song bar sometimes even
those who do the washing take advantage
of the cool waters in mid-april the
anche base of the 1st Air Cavalry
Division is a busy installation the
great heliport known throughout all
Vietnam as the Golf Course is the center
of continuous night and day activities
the helicopters of this air mobile
division are in constant operation
carrying out troop lists schedules
logistics support missions combat
assaults or reconnaissance flights
ground control teams and maintenance
crews are on duty around-the-clock big
cargo carriers like the Chinook keep
troops in the forward areas resupplied
with everything they need small
observation choppers are also part of
the division Pio and E maintenance on
this one calls for inspection of the
airframe and control linkage in a land
of undeveloped jungle country and
limited supply lines helicopter wrecks
are carefully salvaged or whatever parts
may still be safely used nothing is
wasted here Vietnam highway 70 running
through the division camp is one of the
main
traffic arteries in the area with the
rapid growth of the camp it has become
necessary to add on more roadway to
handle the increased traffic the combat
engineers are carrying out the task the
construction of this standard Bailey
bridge is part of the highway
improvement plan the bridge comes
completely packaged and like an erector
set is put together on the spot as each
section is assembled it is joined to the
next and projects it across the gully on
rollers traditionally the monsoon season
will soon be here and the dust will turn
to mud when it does the men of the first
Air Cav will be ready
Cameron Bay is the setting in late April
for the first stage in the construction
of a convalescent center the foundations
are set by men of an engineer unit
medics join in on the construction
located in the Baker Beach area on the
northern end of the peninsula this new
medical complex is designed to take some
of the pressure off the overworked
Hospital at Metron some 30 kilometers
along the coast to the north
construction for the entire project is
to be 50% complete in June
an advanced training test for radar men
known as the ground surveillance
qualification course is given in field
Flake in Germany in late April devised
last year by members of the 3rd armoured
division the GS QC is given to all its
manoeuvre battalions plus division
artillery headquarters it consists of a
day and a night test aims of the GS QC
include information on the combat
readiness of surveillance teams
individual recognition of proficient
radar crewmen and it adds competition to
training inspiring both pride and skill
they are tested on their ability to spot
artillery ATC's trucks Jeeps
tanks and small infantry patrols at
distances from twelve hundred meters to
eight kilometers for the test any
combination of targets is used to make
up a total of ten different targets they
move at varying speeds ranges and
directions according to their scores
successful teams are awarded patches
teams placing first second and third in
the overall competition are awarded
trophy
at the beginning of May some of the
unit's participating in operation
southern arrow neat in Mainz Germany the
men and equipment are part of a joint
operation of the US Army and Air Force
in Europe in a preliminary step troops
assemble at the robert e lee barracks
there they form a convoy to drive to one
of the airlift points of departure which
has been established at the rhein-main
Air Force Base more than 1,900 tons of
equipment over 4,000 men and hundreds of
vehicles reach air bases including
Erding and noida birds rows of c-130s
fill all available parking places ac 124
cargo plane is being unloaded so that it
can be used to carry equipment for the
operation an old one is guided down the
ramp
quartermaster troops prepare a jeep for
airdrop all loose gear must be tied down
and cushioned using to assembly lines
the men buckle down vehicles and
howitzers padding contact points with
honeycomb installation they complete
this job four hours ahead of schedule
the vast quantity of supplies and
equipment are placed aboard the aircraft
on schedule however bad weather delays
the start of the operation one day every
available space at the airfield is
utilized officers and men check over
every detail of the massive operation in
which 2,000 men will hit the silk on 8
May the word is go and the combat loaded
troops line up to board the air Armada
over their objective about eight
kilometers northeast of life I'm the
jump signal is given in rapid order the
men clear the jump door with a sea
1:30 flying at space intervals each
aircrew is in effect a lead crew must
find the drop zone and figure its own
releasing point the intricate schedule
of operations is performed with
remarkable accuracy parachute low
altitude delivery is demonstrated in
Europe for the first time exercise
director Brigadier General Charles M
Geddes 8th Infantry Division assistant
commanding general said of the air
operation the best I've ever seen
in New York City on 15 May the
University Heights campus of New York
University is the scene of a special
ceremony within the university's
renowned Hall of Fame will be installed
a bus to Brigadier General Sylvanus
fair known as the father of the United
States Military Academy the ceremonies
begin as General Omar Bradley troops a
line of Military Academy cadets and
their color guards general Bradley is
among the many dignitaries present to
honor general fare as the superintendent
who drastically reorganized the
Academy's educational system thereby
becoming the founder of technical
education in the United States the
assembled guests enter the library
auditorium for the formal unveiling of
the bus nearby the Hall of Fame stands
silent ready to add its newest military
member to the 93 great Americans whose
bronze portrait busts line the colonnade
among them is Civil War General William
Tecumseh Sherman and general robert e
lee authors artists scientists and
statesmen and a single empty pedestal
awaits a general and educator Sylvanus
fair academy superintendent from 1817 to
1833 inside the library auditorium dr.
Ralph W Stockman director of the Hall of
Fame introduces general Bradley and
presides over the unveiling of the bus
Major General Donald D Bennett present
superintendent of the Military Academy
delivers the major tribute to general
Baio
he became known as the father of the
Military Academy he became known as the
father of the technological schools in
the country engineering schools and he's
become known as a great American you
were celebrating that here today his
election to the Hall of Fame the keynote
address is delivered by general Bradley
representing former president dwight d
eisenhower absent for reasons of health
we know of course that general
eisenhower is very disappointed that he
was unable to be here today in person
because he had been looking forward to
this occasion for many weeks the Thayer
educational system was triangular and
planned with equal sides of education
and discipline arising from an equally
solid base of integrity his methodology
of rigid infants requirements to
eliminate the unqualified candidates for
admission to the Academy the division of
classes in the small sections with daily
recitations on the part of each cadet
and the grades they're on posted weekly
the advancement by merit with a minimum
standard below which no cadet could
remain the application of learn by doing
these were entirely new principles in
American education at that time next dr.
Stockman makes a special presentation to
general Bradley I have a gift to make to
general Bradley you know better you may
think this is a bullet or what but it's
not
this this is the first medal of Sylvanus
there I think as you know we are Hall of
Fame using medals for the rows in the
Hall of Fame about half of them already
honored in that way now this is the
issue of Sylvanus there and I take PI
pleasure in giving the first copy to you
a tape of President Eisenhower's address
is played for the audience in it he
states the general Fair's ideals of duty
honor and country can serve Americans
today the ceremonies are climaxed by dr.
James M Hester president of New York
University who accepts the bust in
behalf of the Hall of Fame and the
university we have all been privileged
this afternoon to participate in a
moment of American history
you